D
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
KAMALA HARRIS PICKING THE WRONG
TIME TO GO WOKE AFTER HURRICANE
IAN WREAKED HAVOC ON FLORIDA.
THE MONSTER STORM DESTROYING
ENTIRE CITIES.
DOZENS ARE DEAD HAD MORE THAN
HALF A MILLION AMERICANS ARE
STILL WITHOUT POWER.
SOMEHOW THE VP IS USING THIS
TRAGEDY TO PUSH FOR RADICAL
IDEOLOGY.
>> IT'S OUR LOWEST INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED
BY THESE EXTREME CONDITIONS.
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS IN A WAY
THAT IS ABOUT GIVING RESOURCES
BASED ON EQUITY, UNDERSTANDING
THAT WE FIGHT FOR EQUALITY BUT
WE ALSO NEED TO FIGHT FOR
EQUITY.
NOT EVERYONE STARTS OUT AT THE
SAME PLACE.
>> Jesse: SPOKESPERSON FOR
RHONDA SANTOS ACCUSING HARRIS OF
CAUSING UNDUE PANIC AND
DEMANDING THAT SHE CLARIFY HER
REMARKS.
ELON MUSK TWEETING RESOURCES
SHOULD BE ACCORDING TO GREATEST
NEED.
LATER IGNORING REPORTERS.
>> CAN YOU CLARIFY WHAT YOU
MEANT ABOUT EQUITY?
>> Jesse: LIKE ALWAYS, THE
WHITE HOUSE IS TRYING TO CLEAN
UP HER MESS.
>> WE ARE COMMITTED TO QUICKLY
GETTING RESOURCES TO ALL
COMMUNITIES IMPACTED, PERIOD.
WE ALSO KNOW SOME PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY IN LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES HAVE A HARD TIME
ACCESSING THAT HEALTH.
THAT'S WHY THIS ADMINISTRATION
HAS ALSO MADE IT A PRIORITY TO
REMOVE BARRIERS AND ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF THEIR
ZIP CODE CAN ACCESS FEDERAL
RESOURCES.
THAT'S WHAT SHE WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
>> Jesse: IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT SAYING WHITE
FLORIDIANS SHOULD GET THEIR
HURRICANE RELIEF LAST?
>> Greg: YES.
WE SHOULD BE SHIFTING THIS AID
FROM UKRAINE TO IRAN.
ONE IS A COMMUNITY OF COLOR AND
WHAT ISN'T.
THERE'S AN OLD JOKE, EARTHQUAKE
STRIKES.
WOMEN AND MINORITIES HIT
HARDEST.
THAT WAS THE JOKE.
NOW THE JOKE IS THE REALITY.
IT'S IN EVERY SINGLE SITUATION.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GO TO.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
EQUALITY AND EQUITY AND THERE'S
BEEN A SLEIGHT-OF-HAND OR THE
LEFT HAS REPLACED EQUALITY WITH
EQUITY.
EQUALITY SEEKS TO GET A LEG UP
FOR EVERYBODY.
EQUITY IS ABOUT EVERYBODY
GETTING A LEG DOWN, FORCED
EQUALITY FROM ABOVE.
RATHER THAN AN ON-RAMP ON THE
LADDER OF OPPORTUNITY.
PUNISH EVERYBODY, PUT EVERYBODY
DOWN A RUNG.
EVERYONE IS GOING TO BE TREATED
CRAPPY.
THE AMERICAN RESPONSE TO
DISASTER IS IMPRESSIVE BECAUSE
THERE IS NO TEAM SPORT, NO RACE
CARD, NO GENDER DEBATE.
EVERYBODY PITCHING IN.
THEY DON'T ASK YOU WHO YOU VOTED
FOR.
KAMALA PROVES YOU CAN INJECT
POLITICS AND WOE GIVES HIM AN US
VERSUS THEM IDEOLOGY INTO
EVERYTHING.
IT'S LIKE A POISON.
THIS IS ONE OF MOST POWERFUL
ASPECTS OF AMERICA, THE MELTING
POT.
OTHER COUNTRIES DON'T HAVE THIS.
IT'S -- IT ATTRACTS THE MOST
INTERESTING PEOPLE BECAUSE WE
SELF SELECT FOR RISK TAKERS.
THAT IS THE TREAT OF THE MELTING
POT.
THE ONLY THING THEY CAN BEAT THE
MELTING POT IS WOKEN SOME.
BY SAYING NO.
YOU'RE DIFFERENT AND THAT MEANS
YOU CAN'T HAVE THE SAME
CONVERSATION.
EVERY TIME YOU TRY TO REACH OUT
AND BE THE SAME, THAT'S
APPROPRIATIONS ON SEVEN OF THE
MELTING POT IT IS SPLITTING
EVERYONE INTO TRIBES.
IN THE LONG RUN IT WILL DESTROY
THE COUNTRY.
IT'S ONE OF THE GREATEST POWERS
WE HAVE.
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT'S MIND
TO BE IN FLORIDA ON WEDNESDAY.
HE MIGHT BE ASKED ABOUT THIS.
I'M SURE HE IS KNOCKING TO BE
TOO HAPPY.
>> Sandra: COVERING THIS
HOLIDAY I CAN TELL YOU THE
VICE PRESIDENT STILL IS NOT PUT
OUT A STATEMENT, TRIED TO WALK
BACK OR CLARIFY THOSE REMARKS.
THAT'S PRETTY AMAZING
CONSIDERING WHAT WE ARE STILL
SEEING AS FAR AS DAMAGE, THE
MASSIVE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
AFFECTED.
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF WHY.
SHE KNEW WHAT SHE SAID WAS
DIVISIVE.
WHY IN THAT MOMENT DID SHE
DECIDE TO BE THAT DIVISIVE.
YOU LOOK AT THE
PRESS SECRETARY'S WORDS IN THE
GAGGLE.
SHE SAID --
SHE SHOULD HAVE ENDED IT.
SHE WENT ON TO DEFEND THE
VICE PRESIDENT'S WORDS SAYING
WHAT SHE MEANT TO SAY.
WHAT SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT WAS
HELPING PEOPLE IN LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES, THOSE THAT HAVE A
HARDER TIME ACCESSING HELP.
ENSURING EVERYONE HAS ACCESS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT SHE SAID.
SHE PRECISELY SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION FOCUS ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
RESOURCES WILL BE BASED ON
EQUITY THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO KEEP FOCUSING EXACTLY ON HER
WORDS.
BILL MAHER WAS AMAZING REACTING
TO THIS.
THE LEFT IS REACTING CALLING HER
OUT.
HE IS SAYING SHE IS GOING TO
LIKELY BE A POLITICAL LIABILITY,
POINTING OUT SHE IS NOT POPULAR
AND QUITE FRANKLY HE SAID SHE'S
JUST A BAD POLITICIAN.
>> Jesse: WHY DON'T WE LISTEN
TO BILL MAHER AND THEN YOU CAN
REACT.
>> IT'S HARD TO TAKE THE
NOMINATION AWAY FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
WHAT I COULD SEE IS REPLACING
THE VICE PRESIDENT.
[APPLAUSE]
SHE'S NOT VERY POPULAR ANYWHERE
AND IT DIDN'T SEEM TO WORK OUT.
I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S BEEN DONE BEFORE ON A
TICKET.
THINK SHE'S A BAD POLITICIAN.
I THINK SHE'S A VERY BRIGHT
PERSON.
>> Jesse: THE LIBERAL
AUDIENCES APPLAUDING THE IDEA OF
REPLACING THE FIRST FEMALE BLACK
VICE PRESIDENT.
>> Jessica: THERE IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BILLABLE MARR
LIBERAL AND A TRADITIONAL
LIBERAL.
DOING SOMETHING DIFFERENT THAN
MAINSTREAM LIBERAL POLITICS BUT
IT'S NO SECRET SHE ISN'T
POPULAR.
SHE HAD TO DROP OUT OF THE
PRIMARY BEFORE ONE VOTE WAS
CAST.
VAN JONES MADE A REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT.
ALONG WITH THE PERSON FROM THE
ATLANTIC TALKING ABOUT IDENTITY
POLITICS AND DEMOCRATS ARE THE
ONLY ONES GETTING SMEARED FOR
PLAYING IDENTITY POLITICS.
CHOOSING MIKE PENCE.
DONALD TRUMP, SAID NOT A
PARTICULARLY SAINTLY FELLA.
HE FOUND A STRONG EVANGELICAL
PARTNER WHO COULD STAND BY HER.
-- STAND BY HER
CONNECTING.
NOT ONLY DEMOCRATS THAT DO THAT.
I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING ABOUT
THE COMMENTS.
SOMEBODY ASKED A TWO-PART
QUESTION.
THE FIRST PART, --
WHAT IS HER NAME?
>> Katie: IT IS HER MAIDEN
NAME.
>> Greg: MARRIED TO JONAS,
VERY IMPORTANT.
>> Jesse: TO ONE OF THE JONAS
BROTHERS?
>> Katie: YES.
>> Jesse: TMC.
>> Jessica: THIS IS NOT WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT.
SHE ASKED A TWO-PART QUESTION.
ONE PIECE WAS ABOUT THE DISASTER
AID RELIEF AND THE OTHER WAS
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF GLOBAL
EMISSIONS.
>> Greg: WHICH SHE IS GUILTY
OF.
>> Jessica: OKAY.
KAMALA HARRIS WAS TALKING ABOUT
WITH THE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR,
THE IMPACT ON COUNTRIES,
CARIBBEAN COUNTRIES THAT GOT THE
WORST OF IT WITH EMISSIONS
VERSUS OTHER COUNTRIES THAT ARE
SHEATH POLLUTERS.
EVERYONE IS LAUGHING AT ME.
THIS IS REALLY WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
>> Jesse: NO ONE IS LAUGHING.
>> Jessica: IT WAS A MUCH MORE
NUANCED ARGUMENT.
THE FEMA DIRECTOR BACKED UP
KAMALA HARRIS.
>> Sandra: WHY IT DOESN'T SHE
COME OUT AND SAY SOMETHING?
>> Jessica: I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jesse: APPARENTLY THIS JUST
WENT OVER EVERYONE'S HEAD.
IT'S MUCH MORE NUANCED AND
COMPLICATED FOR US CRETINS TO
UNDERSTAND.
>> Katie: WHEN YOU ENGAGE IN
THE WOKE BUREAUCRACY IN THE
MIDDLE OF A CRISIS WHICH IS
BEGINNING PART THE MELTING POT
BY JUST DECIDING AND THINKING
ABOUT, THESE PEOPLE ARE HERE AND
ARE THEY MORE OPPRESSED AND WE
HAVE TO DECIDE WHO'S MORE
DESERVING OF THE GRIEVANCE AWARD
INSTEAD OF JUST SAYING THERE'S A
HURRICANE.
PEOPLE IN EVERY COMMUNITY THAT'S
EFFECTIVE NEED THE HELP THEY
NEED.
THAT TAKES UP TIME AND
RESOURCES.
THE ARGUMENT SHE'S MAKING, IF
YOU TAKE OUT THE WILDNESS,
PEOPLE DO NEED RESOURCES AND
HELP.
THE PRESIDENT WAS IN
PUERTO RICO, INTERESTING PLACE
TO TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
HE SAID HE WENT THERE BEFORE
LEAVING THE WHITE HOUSE BECAUSE
PEOPLE OF PUERTO RICO HAVE NOT
BEEN TAKEN CARE OF PROPERLY.
TODAY HE COMMITTED 160 BILLION
MORE DOLLARS TO PUERTO RICO.
HE IS IGNORING AND DOING THAT
HE'S IGNORING ALL THE CORRUPTION
IN PUERTO RICO.
2019.
SOMEONE WHO IS WORKING --
SUPPOSED TO REBUILD THE ELECTRIC
GOLDEN -- GRADE IN PUERTO RICO
PLEADED GUILTY TO WIRE FRAUD.
YOU HAD ALL THIS MONEY A CAPTAIN
FALSE WIRE FRAUD CASES IN
PUERTO RICO.
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
GOVERNMENT RUN WHERE HORSES
FOUND BY LOCAL JOURNALISTS
STOCKED FULL OF BABY FORMULA,
SUPPLIES, SHEETS, FOOD, WATER,
AN ALUM OF THE MONEY WE GAVE TO
THEM AFTER HURRICANE MARIA
WASN'T SPENT OR IT WAS STOLEN BY
CORRUPT OFFICIALS IN PUERTO RICO
SO IF YOU'RE REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE TO HELP
THEY NEED WE SHOULD FOCUS ON
CORRUPTION IN PLACES LIKE
PUERTO RICO AND GET OUT OF THIS
WOKE OLYMPICS WHEN IT COMES TO
SOLVING A PROBLEM.
>> Jesse: ARE ALLOWED TO STEAL
THE MONEY YOU GIVE THEM BUT IF
YOU HAND OUT AID LIKE THIS LIKE
YOU'RE SHOOTING A BASKETBALL
INTO A CROWD.
>> Jessica: IT WAS INCREDIBLY
DEMEANING.
>> Jesse: DEMEANING?
EVERYBODY LOVED IT.
THEY LOVED IT.
>> Greg: 'S SAVES ME A HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS.
>> Jessica: MORE CORRUPTION
AND PUERTO RICO ONE DONALD TRUMP
WAS PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: IT'S GOTTEN WORSE
UNDER THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE OPPRESSED.
>> Jesse: YOU SAID YOU WANTED
THEM TO BE THE 51ST STATE.
WE ARE TAKING YOU AT YOUR WORD.
UP NEX